small lab circuits
thank you
so i'm going to talk about satisfied
radio algorithm for small deep sockets
with symmetric gates
and
of course this talk is about algorithm
design and complexity theory
and our contribution is circuit
algorithms for interesting circuit
classes
and
its implications are circuit side lower
bounds by known results
and this is our problem
in the circuit sat
input is a boolean circuit like this
and output is yes if there exists some x
such that c of x is one and no otherwise
and such dosat is
a canonical np complete problem
and it can be solved in time 2 to the n
times
4 of size of c
and here n is the number of variables
and we denote by this
when
input only comes from a circuit class c
and c is for example c n f
s c 0
s 0 p
s c c 0 t c 0 and c 1 and so on
and these are general research goals
and first
we would like to design
non-trivial algorithms for
stronger circuit classes
and non-trivial means
superpolynomially or exponentially
faster than 2 to the n
and
stronger
is with respect to
these relationships
and second
we
if non-trivial algorithms exist for c
sat then we would like to improve the
running time
and
prove
the difficulty of improvement if this is
not possible
so
what why do we study circuit sat
first
it is useful because
it can encode many combinatorial
problems efficiently
and also
the study sometimes inspires algorithms
for
other problems such as orpia's shortest
path
and second
there's a connection to circuit lower
bounds
and it is known that
non-trivial sysad algorithms imply
that
an expo is not a subset of c
in black box manner
here next
is
non-deterministic exponential time
and also uh the analysis of csat
algorithm sometimes is
average case lower bounds
by
these papers
so
let me define some circuit classes
kcnf is a conjunction of disjunctions of
retailers
and
an ancient circuit is a constant dips
unbounded fine
such with and or not to gates
and s 0 p circuit is an h 0 circuit with
modulo p gates where
p is a prime power
and
an
acc 0 circuit
is an h0 circuit with
modular m gates where m is an arbitrary
integer
ac0 circuit is a constant deep circuit
with
linear threshold gates
and arrhenius threshold gate
can be written as
this form
sine of
weighted sum of variables minus some
constant
and
in c1 circuit is a circuit
where each gate has found in two found
one
and ckt denotes a general boolean
circuit
and we
denote this
to mean a composition of two circuit
classes c1 and c2
so for example cnf is a composition of
end and
or and
usually we assume the number of gates
is
40 n
unless otherwise specified
okay
let's see the research frontier
the frontier is the class tc0
for
non-trivial c sub algorithms
there is um
algorithm for
this class acc0
threshold with a super
super polynomial number of gates
however
as for deepest threshold circuits
such
algorithm is only known when the number
of wires
is at the most linear
and
as for lower bounds for circuit classes
is well known that
majority
and modular q can't be computed by ac 0p
and
next is not a subset of acc scc0
threshold
but
as for tc0
it is only known that
parity can't be computed by
diff dtc0 with
this number of wires
or this number of gates
so
this is
subquadratic
and this is
sublinear in general
and in this talk
i report some new seasat algorithms
and
the first group can be said as
attempts to handle general tc0
and
we consider
two classes
ac 0 with a limited number of symmetric
gates
and
dips to threshold circuits with a sub
quadratic number of gates
and the second group can be said as fast
algorithm within h zero p
and we consider systems of degree k
polynomial equations over gf2
and this circuit classes and
ac 0p
so let's see each result
so
we would like to think about some
interesting class c
that is a subset of tc0 but
not a subset of htc zero threshold
so we consider
s 0 with t of n symmetric gates
of course we don't know
this class
is
not a subset of h e c 0 threshold but
probably
so
and
we need some definitions
a function f is symmetric if
f can be written as
this form
that is
g of sum of variables
n g is the sum function
and
f is weighted symmetric if
f can be returned g of
weighted sum of variables
and you can see that
and or parity module m and
majority are symmetric functions
and linear threshold function is
weighted symmetric
okay
so
is this class interesting
the answer is yes
because
it contains
max sat
when deep seed 2
and t of n is 1.
and
non-trivial algorithms for max three
that is open
so
this class is interesting and
as for our bonds
it is known that
generalized inner product
can't be computed by sc0 with
this number of symmetric gates
or this number of
linear threshold gates
and this is
our first results
we consider this class h 0 with t l
and weight
weighted symmetric gates
where t of n is sub polynomial in
and
the maximum weight is at the most
into the 0.99
and
we show there is a non-trivial
deterministic algorithm for
uh
counting volume c sat
here we assume uh the evaluation of
symmetric gate is f shared
in the corollary we have
max that can be solved in deterministic
time due to the n minus
into the one of order k
when
the number of closes is at the most into
the k
and
therium implies a lower bond of this
form
and my questions
uh
is this
lower bound new and if so then is it
interesting
i looked at some papers
but i couldn't find this type of
results so
i believe
this result
and this is
our
technical results
it is an algorithm for this class of
circuits
and
yeah we show
a deterministic algorithm for the
accounting version of csat that runs in
this time
it's really complicated but
so
our algorithm is based on
so-called concentrated
concentrated shrinkage technique
and
a standard dynamic programming
and then
our theorem holds from this lemma and
some standard transformation techniques
from
this circuit class to this circuit
and
we use
the results from these
three papers
i do not go into the details
okay
so let's move on to dips to threshold
circuits
so
now
we think about another
grass c that is dips to threshold
circuit
and
it is known that uh
this c sub can be solved in time due to
the n times 1 minus mu of c
where mu of c's
dysfunction
and
the number of wires in input circuit is
cn
so
this band is non-trivial if
cn is at the most little order
n log n over log log n
and as for lower bounds as i said
parity can't be computed by
dips d t 0 with this number of wires or
this number of gates
and
we show that
if the number of gates
is m
then
we can solve
c sat
in by a randomized algorithm
in time this
so
this
algorithm is non-trivial if m is
at most n square
and
note that the number of gates is upper
bounded by the number of wires
and here are some questions
can we
randomize this algorithm
because unfortunately this algorithm is
two-sided error randomized algorithm so
we can't apply
the known connections
between
sata algorithms and
circuit lower bounds
if you could apply them would you get a
new low bound
i mean if it was a deterministic
algorithm
yeah
what would be the low point so the row
boundary is this
and
maybe
we don't have to use such a connection
to get a new one
and
also an interesting question
okay
so this is a
blue sketch
and
our algorithm is based on the polynomial
method and circuit complexity
and
we basically follow the framework for
acc 0 threshold
due to linear williams
and
as ingredients we use
a probabilistic polynomial for threshold
and
we also need some transformation
techniques
and
also we use fast evaluation algorithm
for symmetric symmetric due to
idioms
so i'll explain some details later
but
first
i would like to talk about the third
results
so now
i look
inside
this acc 0
and
what are known for these grasses
and it is known that
kcnf sat can be solved in this time
so to the n times 1 minus mu of k where
mu of k is 1 over order k
and
c and f sub can be solved in this time 2
to the n times 1 minus mu of c where mu
of c is one value
and
the number of closes is at the most here
and a c 0 sub can be solved during this
citizen
times 1 minus mu of c d
yeah
this function
and
input is depth d
and the number of gates is atmosphere
and hcc0 sat can be solved in
e where
mu of n d
is this function
again this is d
and in this case the number of gates
is at the most
totally energy
and these are
our new
seasat algorithms
so
first um
we consider systems of degree k
polynomial equations over gf2
and this is equivalent to
the set of
and x y and k
and
this class contains kcnf as a special
case
and
our algorithm still runs in the same
time
as
the top
that for kcnf
second we consider this circuit class x1
x1 and x1
and again this contains cnn as a special
case
and
the running time
is still the same
for cnn
yeah
we assume the number of undergates at
the depth 4 is at the most cn
the number of
gates of this level is at the most here
and we
also show that
ac 0 psat can be solved in this time
and
this
also generalized
algorithm whole hcl thought
is
almost
the same running time
so
for
h0 the running time is this
and
if
we replace this cn by
m
then
this part becomes m over n
so
essentially
the running time is same
in this case
if this is
something like in to the 1.1
okay and this is a proof sketch
again
our algorithm is based on the polynomial
method
and
in this case
we use
these probabilistic polynomials
lines four and and y
and another is
h zero p
and
we
also use fast evaluation algorithm for
polynomial
and
and
i should say that the first item is
essentially due to locustanova and the
battery
the
yeah they gave an algorithm for kcna
based on the polynomial method
and
for second item we use
a technique
called the degree
degree deduction
for
this class of circuits
and this technique
extends a
so-called shrub with this reduction for
cns
so
let me explain
how to design
algorithms using
the polynomial method
so what is the polynomial method this is
an example
due to
fragile and the smallest key
and they showed that
sc0p
can be well approximated by a low degree
gfp polynomial
and they also show that majority
and
modulo q
can't be
were approximated by a low degree
polynomial
so
combining these two
we have
majority
and modulo q
can't be computed by h 0p
and this
item 1
is useful in algorithm design
and
i'd like to note that in general um
[ __ ]
suffices instead of rotariness
so let me define
probabilistic polynomials
so
we fix some polynomial
and
we say this derivation p over
polynomials is an epsilon error
probabilistic polynomial for f
if
this condition holds
that is
for any x
the probability that p of x is not equal
to f of x is at the most
epsilon
where the probability is
taken over this distribution capital p
and
we can define the degree of this
probabilistic polynomial p in the
natural way that is
the degree of capital p is atmospheric
if the probability that degree of
little p is at the most d is one
and
we can also epsilon l of probabilistic c
circuit
number three
and now
i can explain an abstract algorithm for
csat
our input is the circuit c in this
circuit class
and in step one
we define a
such c prime
which is in uh or
c
like this
so
this is a
big or of the original circuit see
i'm sorry which circuit which circuit
class are we talking about now
now
uh c is arbitrary
yeah
framework yes right
so
the ois take over this range
so the resulting circuit is
exponentially larger than the original
circuit
and in step two
we construct a
one over three error probabilistic
polynomial p for c prime in
some time that depends on in employment
the size of c and in step 3
we evaluate
this p
for all
possible assignments
in
time t prime
which is also depends on n and n prime
and the size of c
and
finally
we repeat these two steps or n times to
reduce the error probability
and
output is a candidate through stability
of c prime
and
we have
for any assignment y
uh
probably a probability v o y is not
equal to c prime of y is at the most 2
to the minus 2 n
so
using the union bound uh
we
get a correct true stable breed of c
prime
okay
and
is the williams
favorite he said that he does not use
probabilistic polynomials
yeah basically the same and he actually
use
probabilistic polynomials also
and
the
running time is bounded by
just the sum of
these two
times
so the problem is to up around these two
and now let me implement implement this
algorithm for a specific circuit graph
dips to threshold circuits
and we need several ingredients
and the first one is probabilistic
polynomials
so
the proof and the smallest key showed
that there exists an epsilon error
probabilistic polynomial for and
of degree
log of one over epsilon and it is
eccentric some problem
universal shows that there exists an
epsilon error
probabilistic polynomial for threshold
of degree square root n
polylog no but
it's silo
and again it is efficiently sampled
and this is the second ingredient
that transforms
some circuit glass into another circuit
glass so this rim just says composition
of two polynomials
two layers of polynomials is just a
polynomial
and
machine and series shows that a linear
threshold function can be simulated by
hg02
sim
circuit
and vigil shows that
and sim circuit can be simulated by a
weighted
symmetric function
and this is the third ingredient
so
um
let the c be
sucked in this
seam weighted seam
and
we assume that
top gate has fine
u
and
bottom gates have a
maximum weight w
such that
uw
is
at the most due to the zero point yn
then
the truth table of c
can be generated in time
due to the n times
polynomial of n
and
this is the result of implementation
that one is
same
and in step two
we construct a one over three error
probabilistic circuit
c double prime for
c prime and this c double prime
is in this class
and we can transform this c
double prime using uh
some lemmas into
c 3 prime
which is in
x y weighted sim
and now
we can evaluate this c 3 prime for y and
we repeat
step three to four
modal m times
to reduce the error probability
yeah basically we replace each gate by
polynomials
uh but
we also use
this simulation
oh unlike the bottom layer
the top one it's a point swap
so this means some constant number of
xor
of the circuit in the new simulation of
threshold in 802
yeah
it's
i think at the most deep vibe
and
um
just some
uh tedious calculation we get this
theorem
so
to
randomize our algorithm
we have to randomize
a construction
polynomial them is because the degree is
so the square probabilistic
very bad for the proper state formula
yes
sorry
is this termination
for the bologna for or
yeah actually there's some results like
that
yeah
and i
also like to mention some other
techniques
finds
a technique so called degree deduction
and which states that
this circuit
and xor and xor
with
m and gates at
this level
can be computed by decision tree
such that
in this distant tree
each internal node queries a linear
equation of the home x is
equal to b
where the rank of this matrix is
log m of n
and
each leaf queries a system of degree d
polynomial equations
where
these again log of m over n and
if
this
leaf is reached after l times yes
yes means this equation is satisfied
then
the system
this system defined
over the linear space of dimension
and minus this number
and
the number of leaves each by l times s
is at the most this
this is really complicated but
actually uh this is
a
generalization of so-called surah reduce
reduction for cnf
and
my question is
this
degree
reduction is useful improving average
case lower bonds for hg therapy
as
uh schwarz reduce reduction is useful
improving
average case lower bonds for hc0
and this is
another technique called the bottom of
eye reduction
that states
weighted sim and with
m and locate where m is at the most into
the k
can be computed by a decision tree such
that
each another
node queries are variable x i
and each this queries are
weighted sim and the circuit
because bottom of in is at most moda k
and the total number of leaves in this
decision three
is at the most due to the n minus square
root n
and
again my my question is uh is this
useful in producing average case lower
bounds
so let me conclude
we show new see such algorithm for these
classes
and
there are
many open questions
so you would like to have non-trivial
algorithm for
a stronger succeed
such as
this
and
also can we
think
the same result without polynomial
method
because
if we use the polynomial method
the
algorithm
becomes
exponential space algorithm so
yeah
so i would like to
do without the polynomial method
yeah
for lower bounds or just the question by
itself
just
for practical use
because for example if you'd like to
solve a system of polynomial equations
so
the bond depends on the choice of bases
yeah
and
and
yeah the this question means that
uh
other relevant techniques
useful
such as communication complexity proof
complexity or
formulation complexity of mathematical
programming
and we prove the equivalence between the
lower bound for c and non-trivial c such
algorithms
also
can we show some fine grained reduction
between
c certain c prime set for different
classes
okay
so this is the end of my talk thank you
all right let's thank you very much